ROGER STONE CASE ATTACKED THIS
SHOW BY NAME IN COURT TODAY.
FIRST, THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
JUST DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY IN RESPONSE TO
CORONAVIRUS.
YOU’LL REMEMBER FOR A MONTH,
WESTERN LEADERS TOLD US THE
VIRUS WAS UNDER CONTROL AND
UNLIKELY TO CAUSE SERIOUS
PROBLEMS FOR ANY ONE IN OUR
HEMISPHERE.
NONE OF THAT WAS TRUE BUT SAYING
IT IS LESS PAINFUL OF THINKING
THE THEOLOGY OF GLOBALISM.
THEY WENT WITH IT.
IN CHINA, AN AGGRESSIVELY
NATIONALIST COUNTRY THAT IF
ANYTHING ELSE DOESN’T HATE
ITSELF, AUTHORITIES ACTED WITH
FORCE WITH MILITARY GREAT
DISCIPLINE, THEY SHUT DOWN THE
CITY OF WUHAN.
THE REST OF THE WORLD WATCHED
THIS HAPPEN IN REAL TIME.
BUT YET ASSURED THEMSELVES THAT
EVERYTHING WAS FINE.
IT WASN’T FINE.
WE KNOW THAT NOW.
AT LEAST 35 COUNTRIES HAVE
CONFIRMED CASES OF CORONAVIRUS
AS OF TONIGHT.
LAST FRIDAY, ITALY REPORTED
SIX.MIDDAY TODAY, THEY HAD 283.
BY TONIGHT, THAT NUMBER HAD
RISEN TO 322.
THAT IS A STEEP TRAJECTORY.
11 PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN ITALY AND
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY IS SHUTTING
DOWN.
IRAN HAS 15 DEATH AND 95 DAYS.
ONE OF THOSE INFECTED IS THE
COUNTRY’S OWN HEALTH MINISTER.
HE LATER APPEARED ON AN A
RAINIAN NEWS PROGRAM TO
RE-ASSURE THAT EVERYTHING WAS
UNDER CONTROL AND COUGHED ON THE
WOMEN INTERVIEWING HIM.
TODAY THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION CONFIRMED
A GENERALIZED OUTBREAK IS
INEVITABLE HERE.
IT’S NOT A QUESTION OF IF THIS
WILL HAPPEN BUT WHEN.
OFFICIALS WARNED AMERICANS FOR
SEVERE DISRUPTIONS TO THEIR
LIVES.
>> INCLUDED DIVIDING STUDENTS IN
SMALLER GROUPS OR A SEVERE
PANDEMIC CLOSING SCHOOLS AND
USING INTERNET-BASED SCHOOLING
TO CONTINUE EDUCATION.
FOR ADULTS, BUSINESSES CAN
REPLACE THE PERSON MEETINGS WITH
VIDEO OR TELEPHONE CONFERENCES
AND INCREASED TELE WORKING
OPTIONS.
ON A LARGER SCALE, COMMUNITIES
COULD HAVE TO CANCEL MASS
GATHERINGS.
DISRUPTION TO EVERY DAY LIFE
COULD BE SEVERE.
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SITUATION.
I WOULD SAY RIGHTFULLY SO.
I’M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SITUATION.
CDC IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
>> Tucker: SO WHAT WILL A
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC MEAN FOR
THIS COUNTRY?
YOU PREDICT WITH PRECISION.
HERE’S ONE FORECAST FROM THE
ATLANTIC.
IT’S TILED "YOU’RE LIKELY TO GET
THE CORONAVIRUS."
THE ARTICLE DESCRIBES A HARVARD
EPIDEMIOLOGY.
THEY SAY --
>> Tucker: NOT ALL OF THEM WILL
BECOME ILL, MANY HE SAYS WILL BE
ASYMPTOMATIC OR FEEL NO WORSE
THAN LIKE WITH A COLD.
70% OF THE WORLD’S POPULATION IS
A BIG NUMBER.
THEY SAY IT’S 4. -- 5.4 BILLION
PEOPLE.
CURRENTLY THE CORONAVIRUS
APPEARS TO KILL ABOUT 2% OF THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE IT.
SO LET’S BE GENEROUS FOR A
MOMENT AND IMAGINE THAT
ASYMPTOMATIC CARE REMEMBERS ARE
NOT DETECTED AND THE REAL DEATH
RATE IS .5%.
EVEN UNDER THAT SCENARIO, THERE
WOULD BE 27 MILLION DEATHS FROM
CORONAVIRUS GLOBALLY.
IN THIS COUNTRY, MORE THAN A
MILLION WOULD DIE.
ACCORDING TO THE ATLANTIC, MANY
EXPERTS FEAR THIS MAY NOT BE A
ONE-OFF EPIDEMIC.
COLD AND FLU SEASON COULD BECOME
COLD, FLU AND CORONAVIRUS SEASON
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
WILL THAT HAPPEN?
OBVIOUSLY WE’RE PRAYING IT
DOESN’T.
BUT WE KNOW ONE THING.
RIGHT NOW AS OF TONIGHT, AMERICA
IS NOT READY FOR THIS OR FOR ANY
MAJOR EPIDEMIC THANK TO THE
CDC’S FLOOD ROLL-OUT, FEWER ARE
EVEN PREPARED TO MONITOR
CORONAVIRUS.
THE ECONOMY IS NOT PREPARED
EITHER.
THE DOW JONES FELL CLOSE TO 900
POINTS TODAY.
THAT’S ON TOP OF YESTERDAY’S